it's difficult to explain people talk
about riots but for those of us who have
to deal with it they aren't riots it's
War the people who are standing in front
of us are there to kill us they have
Molotov cocktails they have Stones they
come to within three meters in front of
us they have enormous paving stones
which they throw at us to try to kill us
not to play with us they are there to
kill us
we must show them that the Republic is
stronger we must have a presence we must
be Discerning we shouldn't be overtaken
by hatred or anger we must arrest judge
and then show them that we respect the
law and that nothing is stronger than
the Republic the police are there to
help people not to mistreat people